the challenge of the week the challenge
that one poor team must face every week
except when the chiefs have their buy
how in the world do you stop the kansas
city offense peter and you know this
comes up especially and i think most
fascinatingly when the patriots and the
chiefs come together because belichick
has that history of creating something
that confounds or at least slows down
just enough the opposing offense so his
offense can score at least one more
point and i think back to super bowl 36
all the time
the masterful decision that really put
belichick on the map as a head coach to
drop eight guys into coverage and and to
to dare mike martz and the greatest
show-offs on turf to throw the ball and
throw the ball and they never deviated
from it and ran the ball instead the
problem and i've been thinking maybe you
should just do that to the chiefs
problem is now if they have clyde
edwards a lair
andy real say fine
put drop gate guys into coverage and and
try to tackle clyde after he gains 15
yards
yeah i think one of the interesting
things if you're a student of history in
this rivalry
you know you saw alex smith
and kareem hunt
put up 42 points with andy reid in 2017
in foxborough first game of the year
one of the greatest scenes ever in uh in
that tom vs time
uh documentary is tom brady in his car
uh range rover whatever with gizelle in
the passenger seat and she's trying to
comfort him
as they leave the stadium that night
and he's having none of it he is like
seething he's you could see the steam
coming out of his ears
so there's that
and then the next year theoretically
when okay
we got we got the new guy and we'll
throw up all this stuff that'll confuse
the new guy and mahomes wasn't perfect
because he threw that bad interception
right before half time in that game
but he still put up 40 points
and then you get to the championship
game mike uh in
in kansas city and belichick did a great
job the patriots did a great job in the
first half but then it was like
almost every time they touched the
kansas city touched the ball after that
they were going to score
so
you get the feeling
that there is this dam
in front of the new england defense and
you hold it hold it hold it but
eventually the dam's gonna burst
and i guess my question is
if you have to play a scoring contest
with the kansas city chiefs if this game
is in the 30s
how will cam newton do and more in
particularly
what will he do in the first three games
week one
19 passes
week two 44 passes
week three 28 passes
i mean
that to me
that's good for the patriots because if
you're steve spagnolo you're watching
them this week and you're studying and
you walk into andy reed's office and say
coach
i i have no idea what these guys are
going to do
but i think this is the game
where cam newton is going to run a lot
because i just think
they say that our best chance
is to put the ball in the hands of cam
newton early and often
and when chris sims and i were talking
about this yesterday the point he made
and this is a good one peter that
the re the the chiefs after just playing
the ravens
on
monday night and
forcing lamar jackson to try to throw
and giving him opportunities to throw
and him not capitalizing on the
opportunities to throw
um you know do you see a similar
defensive game plan from the patriots
will cam newton have to pivot and and
can he do a better job than lamar
jackson did of getting the ball down the
field with his arm and not with his legs
and you know cam newton and patrick
mahomes have never squared off before
and and we know these guys pay attention
to everything even when they claim that
they don't i think the harder they claim
they don't the more that they really do
but all the talk about my homes in
jackson my homes in jackson the great
rivalry i mean here's cam newton he's
new on the scene he's never faced
mahomes before the last time the
panthers and the chiefs played was 2016
before mahomes was drafted so this has
never happened and i could see cam
newton being
more than a little bit upset
that no one's talking about the
potential for
this great quarterback rivalry for as
long as newton's in new england and
patrick mahomes and yeah newton's a
little bit older than mahomes five six
years but but still this is an
opportunity in a roundabout way
for newton to prove to everyone
that he's as good if not better than
lamar jackson when healthy
because if he can do more against that
same defense than lamar jackson did
you and i and everyone else is going to
react to that game on sunday and say
damn
maybe cam newton's as good as lamar
jackson we just have not seen much of it
the past couple of years because he's
been injured
i mean
if if cam newton wants to feel that way
it certainly is his right
but
i don't feel that way
you know i mean for the last year and a
half cam newton has not been whole he's
had two significant surgeries
and he's started out this year very well
now
i don't i still don't know exactly what
cam newton is
the graphic that we just put up just
showed that in essence the patriots are
going to use cam newton obviously in a
much different way than they use tom
brady but week to week i don't know how
they're going to use cam newton
that is the mystery and that is what the
patriots have going for him right now
and
cam newton has every opportunity to
prove
that he belongs
in the discussion with the best
quarterbacks the five best quarterbacks
in football he has that chance it is a
golden chance
with josh mcdaniels and bill belichick
golden chance
but it's a chance it isn't reality it
hasn't happened yet let's see if it does
and one of the important things that i'm
going to be paying attention to
especially if the chiefs build a
double-digit lead at some point you know
we saw late in the game lamar jackson
seemed frustrated
seemed down you know the patrick mahomes
default demeanor no matter what the
score is he's like let's go do it let's
go get it done we're down 10.7 minutes
left in the super bowl let's go take it
right and i think the more success you
have
coming from behind and coming from
behind and coming from behind the easier
it is
to have that that kind of like yeah
we've been here we've done this but with
lamar i i said you know you rarely see
the ravens in that spot and maybe that's
one of the reasons why he seemed
frustrated but that's been one of the
criticisms of cam newton it's a roller
coaster when things are going well when
you get a lead early everything's great
when you just feel like it's not your
day he has a hard time breaking out of
that and this is going to be i think the
biggest test now look against the
seahawks they were done
and they fought back into it and they
made an exciting game right down to the
end so that was positive but that that
may be another part of the test here as
this patriots team grows and develops
with cam newton as the quarterback
dealing with the adversity of being
behind in the second half and having
faith that you can make it happen even
if you feel like it's not going your way
and peter you know i feel about this
game the same way i felt about the
seahawks game for the patriots if this
was later in the year i'd feel better
about the patriots if they cross paths
in the postseason the chiefs and the
patriots i'll feel better about the
patriots for now
i just feel like it's still too much of
a work in progress to go toe-to-toe with
this well-oiled machine that is the
kansas city chiefs
well mike you brought it up um last year
an hour and 15 minutes after the super
bowl pre-covered
uh no mask i walked into andy reed's
coach's office
at the at hard rock stadium sat down
with him for about 12 to 15 minutes and
one of the first things he said was
man how about patrick
and
what everybody says oh well big deal
here's what he meant
you're down by 10 points
with eight minutes to go
and if the game ended right then because
what i said to andy i said andy you know
uh if
if if that game continues on its path
my go to the week would have been
patrick mahomes
you know he didn't come through in the
big moment through a couple of ugly pics
you know and all that
but i said
he willed his way to coming back in that
game and he comes to the sidelines and
nfl films captures it and he says to
eric b enemy hey do we have time to run
wasp
and and and he's he's excited you could
tell he's interested the enemy asked
andy reid can we run two jet chip wasp
you know the play that tyreke hill ends
up doing the very deep out
uh and they go plus 40 they go 44-yard
gain and they win the game
but
that's what i was watching for the other
night and that's what i did not see in
lamar jackson lamar jackson was down at
the end of that game you could see it
now maybe he wasn't down in his voice
but he sure was down in his body
language so
and and and look when you were having
a terrible day
in the biggest game of your life and you
have it in you when it's third and
fourteen to still be excited and still
say hey we got this don't worry
i mean that is the trait of one of the
great quarterbacks and that's the trait
that mahomes has
and it's only gotten stronger and
stronger you know when you
pull that victory out of the fire the
way that they did how does it not give
you confidence you're always going to be
able to do it and conversely the defense
knows your history and they start
feeling a little wobbly like uh oh here
it comes and and that's i think the big
difference right now between patrick and
holmes and most other quarterbacks in
the nfl here he is from earlier in the
week talking about the experience facing
these bill belichick defenses
luckily for us we've played them a good
amount of times now so when you see all
the different types of stuff that they
that they presented us and offenses like
us and so uh you know there's gonna be
on scottish stuff there's gonna be stuff
that he's gonna throw out there i mean
that's why he's one of the best coaches
of all time uh and so we have to make
sure that we are able to make
adjustments quickly and find ways to not
have negative plays and have positive
ones even if it's unscouted
you know the obsession when facing the
kansas city chiefs especially when it's
the patriots has been take away tyree
kill that's what they did in the first
half of that afc championship game a
couple of years ago a deep safety that
shaded over to provide double coverage
of tyree kill neutralizing him the
problem is
they got too many other guys now peter
they got travis kelsey they've always
had him but the clyde edwards a lair
dynamic is what changes this offense and
andy reads patience and ability and
willingness
to use what's available to take what
he's being given that's what sets him
apart from other coaches who just gets
so frustrated that the thing they want
to do isn't there they still keep
banging their head against the wall
until it's there or until it blows up on
them
the chiefs have the ability and the
coaching patience and eric the enemy is
a big part of this too because he's the
one calling the plays to know we just
have to take what's available and at
some point that big play is going to be
available and that was something patrick
mahomes told me going into 2019 that his
next stage for his development is
to be patient
to to not get frustrated when that shot
down the field isn't there and
understand that there's going to be
something shorter that may not be as
sexy but let's take what's there and i
think edward's a lair makes it even
easier for patrick mahomes to settle for
something that's available here instead
of forcing what's down there and you're
screwed if you're the defense you can't
win you can't beat them you can't you
know belichick always says take away
what they do best they do everything
best you can't take it all away
well consider this you know they've got
the fastest wide receivers in the game
uh they have a great tight end who's
either the best or second best tight end
in the game
and they have a rising star running back
so patrick mahomes throws four touchdown
passes the other day
two of them are very typical one is an
all-out bomb to machole hardman and one
is a perfectly thrown
timing route to uh
to tyreek hill the other two
a hunt an underhand touchdown pass to
his fullback
in traffic
and the other one is a touchdown pass to
his left tackle
so you go try to figure out what andy
reid is going to do sunday against new
england i have no clue but i know it's
going to be fun to watch
yeah i'm looking forward to it as well
both sides of the ball because it may
just be
the only way you can beat the chiefs is
to outscore them because they're going
to get their points peter this is
something i've been saying over and over
again it almost qualifies for a spot on
the pft bingo card the chiefs are that
basketball team that's going to go on an
18 to 2 run they will do it at some
point you need to accept it you need
going into the game you need to accept
the fact that at some point it's going
to get a little bit out of control the
question is for the rest of the game can
you do enough to make up for the damage
done by the chiefs in that moment where
it all falls together and you just can't
stop them no matter what they do so it
should be a great game we look forward
to that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports